meet Brianna cuoco kaley cuoco Z Unger
sister they're best friends and
extremely close she truly is the most
generous person I have ever known in my
entire life
after Kayleigh split from Ryan Sweeting
in September it was only natural for the
27 year old singer to lend her support
how are you there for her through the
thick and the thin of it everyone goes
through hard times and as long as you're
there for that person and you know or
they know that you're gonna be there
with no judgment and you can just be a
good sounding board that's all you can
do for someone she's never been better
honestly yeah she's so good she's so
happy
is there like three qualities that
you're looking for in the next guy that
she days I mean I think all the basics
just like nice you know what be nice
don't be a jerk and I think just make
something that she's you know she's a
really great sense of humor something
that makes her laugh makes her feel
comfortable and I'm confident and in
what she's made for herself in her life
speaking of dating the cuoco girls our
self-proclaimed bachelor obsess ease
bachelor it's all [ __ ] social it's all
we're doing really it's watching The
Bachelor it's consuming your lives
I'm and hang with the dogs and and yeah
just enjoying life and working and doing
the show what she loves and she's got
great girlfriends so which makes life a
lot better but don't count on Breanna to
ever appear on the show
are you interested I know I would never
want to be a contestant I think I would
just want to be the Bachelorette but I
think that's harder it's you know what
I'm saying like being the one person and
having there's so many men oh god I
think it would make me sad and then yeah
I think it's really difficult to do that
still when it comes to Bachelor Ben
Higgins Briana is all in then if you
didn't find someone this season
you